pour cette rentrée 2010 8 la région
ile-de-france veut que ces lycéens
manger mieux et on veut du produit local
et puis on veut que dans ce produit
local 50% soit du produit bio donc nous
allons travailler sur cet
approvisionnement senlis et cette année
seront concernés par l'introduction du
bio
l'augmentation des tarifs pour les
parents qui règle le repas de leurs
enfants suivront leur quotient familial
alors pour aider les lycées la région
finance à 40 % les produits bio et à 60%
le bio locale durement au lycée 17 mar
de maurepas on essaie de servir du bio
depuis six ans objectif d'ici la fin de
l'année atteints dans les 10 % de
produits bio dans les plateaux pour
obtenir ces produits locaux le lycée
fait appel au groupement des
agriculteurs bio d'île de france
mais ce n'est pas toujours suffisant et
des moments où ils ont pas forcément
alors soit parce qu'on est trop nombreux
à recommander ou aux clivages n'ont pas
donné assez de lait et la semaine
dernière je n'ai pas eu toute ma vive
raison
ils ont partagé quoi pour tout le monde
puisse en avoir et pas du tout la
livraison de yahoo j'avais demandé je
connais le plus de mal à trouver c'est
la viande car quand on parle
restauration scolaire on parle quantité
on passe à peu près 300 personnes en une
demi heure au maximum ce sont 600 repas
qui sont servis chaque jour d'ouverture
de la demi-pension au lycée jules ferry
de versailles
on explose les compteurs 1300 élèves
sont inscrits à la cantine leur plus
grosse difficulté c'est de trouver des
agriculteurs ou des commerçants qui sont
prêts à jouer le jeu sur le volume
puisque si on prend l'exemple des pommes
de terre aujourd'hui on est sur 350 kg
de pommes de terre pour servir autant de
repas pas moins de 200 ch une
organisation bien rodée donc notre
cuisine fait une production à la minute
au fur et à mesure que les élèves avant
sous les personnes qui sont abonnées
décernant ce qu'on leur fait de la
production on réajuste au plus près de
façon à ne pas perdre le gâchis et avant
un produit sain et de qualité servie
chaleur ici le mot d'ordre est locale le
chef de cuisine s'est rapproché de ses
collègues investi par les mêmes envies
de circuits courts pour créer un réseau
en 2012
nous avons monté l'action toqués du
local qui était d'une réfection de
consommer des produits contribuent au
fournil de nous en ile de france puisque
bien souvent on va chercher des produits
très loin alors que en ile-de-france a
notamment produit que ce soit à 11
dollars en porc en fruits et légumes en
produits laitiers
ce jour là c'est la fête de la
gastronomie l'occasion parfaite de
mettre en avant des produits les plus
locaux possibles des moules de normandie
des produits laitiers de la ferme de
grignon et du réseau français de
différentes variétés
moi je vous fais un assortiment allez on
se fait ça au total 20 % des lycéens
franciliens ont des produits bio dans
leurs plateaux